the Joe Rogan experience boom
live okay what the [ __ ] will you just
tell me my Joey's hi Matt Farah what so
everybody you can see we're just talking
about Rolls Royce yeah because I was
hearing you're in your new baller studio
which congratulations thanks sick
admiring your skylights and we're
discussing the Rolls Royce and the the
star filled ceiling they do yeah which
is they put all these fiber-optic lights
into your headliner and it looks like
the Stars and it's I think it's 15 grand
and not only will they do it so you can
get your standard star pattern which is
just whatever the guy just random bright
random lights or they'll make you exact
constellations if you prefer right here
like a few one of those astrology pedia
or they will make you you know the sky
directly above your house if you give
them a coordinate there's a photo so
badass it's like it's so awesome you're
you're ballin so hard you're so driving
around with a car with stars in the roof
well so the last thing I said before you
hit live was that they have just
announced they have come out with a
shooting star so I feel how it works I'm
not sure exactly what but I guess you
could do you can get shooting stars
you're silly that's crazy what are they
gonna do make the whole thing a big LCD
pattern or something yeah I guess or I
don't know I guess you can you could
have run an LED or a fiber optic line
that works in a some kind of a tray I I
emailed once I got that press release
because I get press releases and I just
delete them I don't you know but when I
saw a shooting star ceiling I responded
kind of further info and video on this
and they said they'd get back to me so
I've never been in one of those things
never know no choice you must what is it
like in there it's like sailing
it's like yachting Phil Hartman had a
really really old I think it was an old
Bentley I mean like really like sixties
old old older than that like 30 it was
[ __ ] old man I wish I paid attention
to cars back then but back then it was
when I just started getting on TV I
really did
I you know when when I was broke I
always loved cars when I was a kid but
then I was broke my attitude was like
don't think about some [ __ ] you're never
gonna be able to afford yeah so just
don't think look at you now Joe Rogan
with all the toys
somewhere to park them somewhere to park
them but he had this old baller looking
thing it was like it was like something
out of Citizen Kane oh yeah just this
incredible hmm boat and you know punchin
fenders the whole deal I think you
shifted it on the tree probably I would
say if I had to guess something baller
that Phil it's like I would say Bentley
Continental s1 would be the most likely
it might have been candidate but he
loved that thing he you just had this
giant smile on his face with that thing
he was like a smile that you love like
ours that's great
Phil Hardman's bit like that something
look at lines yeah I wish I could
remember because like I said back then
like if you asked me to like there's
cars that I don't know [ __ ] about like
Rolls Royces or Bentley's but if you
showed me like an old Porsche I'd be
like oh that's a 73 long nose yeah you
know that we all have our areas like
muscle cars I can I'm a good muscle car
guy I understand most muscle cars yeah
to pick them out in the lineup but well
only in Rolls Royce were are a weird one
because they have sort of this
intertwined history where they were
separate and then they became together
and then they became separate again so
there's a lot of Rolls Royces and
Bentley's that are mostly the same car
those are that's like super baller level
were you like okay look forget about it
let's just get a car that's makes no
sound like you can't hear anything
amazing cars oh they're so [ __ ] cool
dude imagine even like - a lot of car
guys especially like you know you are
such like a manual transmission you know
you want your car I know you you want
your car to be like really close to a
race car I could be in dirty where I
could being gritty like I want to I want
to feel the rocks as I Drive over them
right well you notice you would
appreciate a Rolls Royces ability to
make a hundred percent of that disappear
you know I'm saying like disappear
entirely and like there's really neat
details and like you are the word flying
or floating or sailing is
true because you don't really drive it
you just kind of [ __ ] will it down
the road and you know how it like your
your Porsche or a sports car will have
like the thumb grips on the wheel at
nine and three like so Rolls Royce has
thumb grips at four and and eight really
you drive them underhand gangster
extremely gangster underhand you see let
me feel this it's that you yeah it's
underhand yeah because you don't even
lift your arms above shoulder height and
then you know your car has a tachometer
right it shows you your rpms is there a
rough indicator of how much power you're
using right roughly not exactly but
before people go crazy about the lack of
a technical term Rolls Royces don't have
tachometers they have a power reserve
gauge which shows you how much power the
car has but that you are not using at
any given time whoa right so if you're
if you're coasting along it's at a
hundred going down a hill maybe you're
just off the gas off the brake coasting
there you go power reserve so if you're
coasting you are using zero percent of
your engine right and the idea is to
keep that gauge low because you want to
be able to pass cars and and cruise down
the road right while using 25% of this
cars in July so and there's stupid
horsepower right like crazy right like
not like crazy crazy were like four four
to five hundred so hi yes hi hi hi mark
yes isn't that funny that that saying
that is not that hard for a car of today
our standards are so crazy I'm blown out
our standards the Internet has [ __ ] us
all up
[Applause]